old man xeno classic exotic transmuter
doesn't often engage in conjuration as a
result
however when he does it is to conjure a
subscribe button for the new world
review the pricing of which will grant
you regular hunt onto content
uploaded straight into your youtube feed
hello and welcome to the new order of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we are stepping into the
household of the world's most famous
clan of assassins in an attempt to rank
the zoldic family
now how are we ranking them you ask well
by the only decent metric that we are
able to generate which is sheer
popularity
so about a month ago i put up a straw
poll in our youtube community section
which as of right now has received an
astounding 14 and a half
thousand votes so i feel like we're
going to have a pretty good indicator of
zoltic popularity on display here today
and before we get started
i want to give a shout out to this guy
who took the time to click the straw
poll link and even leave a comment
saying no thanks sorry
which i love because i am certain that
it would have taken them more time to
actually do this than to just
vote in the poll itself so just to amend
my previous statement i guess more
accurately we have 14 and a half
thousand votes and
one abstaining there's always one but
let's jump into things pretty
immediately now with our 10th place
contender kikiozodek and 10th place
probably sounds a bit too glorious
because in reality she is dead last with
a mere 121 votes with that said i am
kind of shocked that there are in fact
121 people out there who would claim
that kikio is their favorite zoltik
whether it be a real opinion or even
just a joke however looking at this more
positively kikio has one
very solid thing going for her which is
a fairly stunning and intriguing design
of all of the zeldik family she is the
most visually distinct most of the other
members tend to be quite understated in
this area which
to be fair makes sense because they are
assassins and probably shouldn't be
dressing to capture attention so i
suppose that you can definitely tell
that kikio married into the zoldic
family and in fact we do know that she
was originally from meteor city as many
in the series are but she is much more
than just a maternal figure and kikyo is
also a trained assassin herself which
throws a lot more credit behind her name
but to me
personally kikio is just the most i
guess boring of the bunch
which is pretty crazy considering her
ornate design but i think that just
speaks to the sheer level of character
presented within the rest of this clan
so speaking of in 9th place we have
piggy i mean milikey who practically
doubles kiki's vote total sitting at 241
ticks of approval and you know i'd never
go
so far as to call milikey a popular
character in fact the sentence just
sounds
weird coming out of my mouth but i can
at least see where these people are
coming from a lot easier than i can with
kikio anyway miloki is a pretty
fascinating zoldic
because much like killua he doesn't
really fit in with this family he's
definitely that disappointing middle
child who grew up to be a weeb with an
extensive collection of anime body
pillows but despite that he is to be
taken very seriously in every respect
because milike is of course a trained
assassin and that
is an interesting fusion of features the
otaku assassin i mean that could be a
series all on its own and i was always
hoping that he would play a bigger part
in hunter hunter especially when he got
involved in all the greed island stuff
and maybe even become a primary
antagonist of that arc as opposed to say
gen through but we got what we got and
what we got
isn't all that much which i suspect is a
huge part of why milike
lands so close to the bottom of the
zodic barrel here today so moving on to
number eight we have the eldest known
living member of this family maha zoldik
who garnered a fairly impressive 355
votes
although that vote count much like the
series of hunt hunter itself may be very
much sleeping on this character
in fact maha has been vaguely praised as
one of the most powerful characters that
this series has
ever featured as it was stated by zeno
that the only person who has challenged
maha and lived to tell the tale would be
isaac netaro but it's very important to
dwell on that statement for a bit
because it doesn't actually say who if
anybody won that confrontation just that
netro survived which
is a pretty alarming thought the fact
that there may be a human in this world
whom even netro could not overcome and a
figure who is still very much alive and
well to this day
potentially even still capable of
devastating power
that is the great mystery of mahatho a
story which we will likely never get to
know in any great amount of detail
and much like milky's role in hunter
hunter that has no doubt contributed
quite strongly to maha being one of the
more neglected zoltics in the minds of
fans so stepping into number seven then
we have a slightly less neglected zelda
being zigg and if you've not read the
manga continuation of hunt hunter beyond
the anime events well this face thing is
probably pretty new to you zig zoltik is
a man who has appeared in a grand total
of one
count of one panels during the short
flashback of a young isaac netro landing
on a dark continent zigg was one of two
companions that netro took with him in
this endeavor
and with that you are now caught up to
speed with everything that we officially
know
about zigg i think that zigg trumps maha
here today because he is a relatively
more recent addition to the story and
fresher in the minds of fans with all of
that said though i do need to state that
there is a very
very real possibility that zigzaldik and
maha zaldik are in fact the same person
this is primarily because they're
aesthetically similar they should be
around the same age and maha's name was
not actually given in either the anime
or the manga it was just stated in a
data book and that kind of information
has been known to change
or just be flat out wrong when it comes
to hunter hunter however right now we
have no real definitive answer to that
inquiry so we do have to treat zig and
maha as different characters although
given that they are side by side here
today i don't think that their ranking
would change all that much
if they were indeed the same character
but now in sixth place we have probably
the most forgotten about zodiac family
member being kalito however at the very
least 536 people did remember him
in fact they very fondly remembered him
but carlito is a pretty stunning enigma
of hunter hunter specifically when it
comes to his decision to join the
phantom troop a position which he
maintains to this very day and allegedly
carlito has done so in order to quote
get my brother back which is a line that
can be examined ad nauseum and i have
plans to do just that in the future but
that's because it is not clear who
kalito is referring to
and for what reason there are all sorts
of thoughts out there such as the target
being kilauea or even alaka but one of
the most fan-favored trains of thought
is the phaeton zodiac theory which
states that he is the missing brother
within his family which is not
actually as absurd of an idea as it
sounds there's actually quite a lot
going in that theory's favor especially
having kalato join the phantom troupe
specifically
to retrieve a certain brother but i
think we've gotten a bit
off topic here so we will now take what
is no less than a gigantic leap upwards
in terms of votes with fifth place being
inhabited by silversodic with a shocking
1668 votes
which for the more mathematically
inclined of you is more than triple the
vote total of kalato so these next five
zolticks are certainly the more favored
within the series silver for obvious
reasons he's kind of like maha
in that he has an established legacy
behind him specifically in regards to
having fought against crolo in the past
and having even defeated a former
unnamed phantom troop member but silva
has also had some nice crowning moments
that we have had the pleasure of seeing
with our own eyes such as a modern fight
against crollo
and having the honor of delivering the
final blow to chitu during the chimera
ant talk but silva is just the kind of
character who i cannot help but be
excited for whenever he appears because
this man means business
if he takes the time out of his day to
be in the story then it is going to be
for a very compelling reason
and while his appearances are still yeah
a bit rare for my liking he definitely
does the best he can
with what he has to work with and
narrowly edging out a victory over silva
would be a late addition to this clan in
alakozodek who managed to generate just
over 1700 votes this does make all the
sense in the world
because alika is one of the very few if
not the only zodiac who has received an
entire arc focusing on them
and alaka also has a slight advantage of
being the host of nanika as well who is
quite literally the most powerful
character within the entire series
and that makes alika a compellingly
scary presence but also adorable at the
same time because her relationship with
killua
is the only one within this entire
family unit that even comes close to the
word wholesome
normal you know what even functional
alaka got to showcase a side of this
family that i did not know was possible
and it's great that kilauea is not the
only zodiac with some form of heart
and desires outside of murder for money
the only slight thing that does bother
me about alakar is that she is a fairly
blatant deus ex machina that was
designed to save gone from his own
foolishness but then again that has
nothing to do with alaka herself so
congratulations on your incredible
popularity but getting very serious now
the bronze medal in the zoltic olympics
will be going to illumi as one of the
most prolific antagonists within this
entire series illumi is very much to be
expected at the top of pretty much any
poll let alone one catered to his family
name but really if it weren't for the
existence of hisoka i think that illumi
would act as something of a hunter
hunter ambassador
because he just has everything going for
him he's quirky
absurdly strong and comes with a sleek
yet effective character design the
combination of which demands the
attention
of any reader or watcher plus he's also
the poster boy for manipulation in the
nin realm really proudly displaying to
us the degrees to which an efficient
user can push pure manipulation
which was far beyond what i thought it
would be capable of when first learning
of the affinity and very importantly
illumi legitimately scares me i mean i
like him
i like him a lot as a character but if i
saw him at any time
anywhere in this world i would probably
promptly crap myself and i think that
that is a sign of a very well done
antagonist as well as a character in
general now as for who defeats illumi
well our runner-up for this list is
going to be one xenozoldic who doesn't
just beat illumi but zeno actually
thrashes him with almost a full 1000
more votes than his grandson and i think
a lot of this is because zeno is the
perfect combination
of every profound zodic feature he has
the legacy and seemingly godlike power
of figures like maha but he also has the
quirkiness and sense of humor of the
younger family members and then again at
the same time he's also a very strict
professional like his son silva
and finally not to be outdone zeno very
much comes with a unique and ornate
design very reminiscent of kikio
everything that comes under the banner
of zoldick is manifest in zeno to the
point where whenever i hear the name
zoldick this man is the immediate image
that comes to mind
zeno is my favorite zoltik family member
is very much what i would like to say
because i do love this character
unfortunately the ultimate zodic killer
just so happens to
exist and it should be no surprise 21
that he has emerged as number one on
this list with
far and away the most amount of votes
sitting at 4
524 which is almost a third of the
entire votes cost
and look maybe it's not fair to put
kilauea as an option here but really we
can't have a zodic popularity poll
and not feature the zoldic the killer is
not just my favorite zoldic he's my
favorite hunthunt character in general
so i could not be more thrilled to see
him emerge victorious
in any respect and there we have the
official new world review zaldik family
ranking
and you know i'd still like to do some
more of these polls because i find all
of your thoughts really fascinating here
so if there is a particular ranking you
would like done then please do let me
know down in the comments i was thinking
about doing a chimera antoine but
there's an
awful lot of ants i mean maybe they
could be separated somehow like squadron
leaders or even a shorter one with a
royal guard but yeah
you guys let me know what you want to
see but what do you guys think please
leave your thoughts in the comments
below or even join my discord server and
if you're keen for some more hunt hunter
content then please do go and check out
some of my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel for regular
hunter hunter glory delivered straight
into your youtube feed but for now this
has been the new world review and i'll
see you next time